I'm here to talk through a horrific
incident that occurred last night which
resulted in a 31y old female and two
children aged three and eight being
attacked with a corrosive substance
which we now confirm to be an alkaline a
35-year-old male called Abdul eedi um
and he left the scene um but the
injuries to the female and children and
they're in a stable condition but we are
just monitoring but they don't seem to
be uh life-threatening but at this time
they could be lifechanging we're
liaising with our local other partners
agency so we're working alongside North
Umbria we believe the male is from the
Newcastle area um and he could be going
back there he may not be but he could be
um btp British transport police are also
working alongside us as well so we are
working in collaboration with other
agencies to try and locate this Mount uh
just screaming and shouting and uh they
hear what they were
screaming uh stop no and all that and
the screams and uh but obviously if you
got get involved something seriously
happened to
[Music]
you